what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 3rd of may
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen
you know how much fun it is just to
watch a sporting event
with a little bit of money on it just to
make a little bit more interesting i'm
talking about 25 bucks 30 bucks
just something you know listen this week
i didn't watch the ufc
uh with dominic reyes but last week i
did and it was just a small bit on the
end and i had fun and the game was more
interesting this saturday
two of boxing's most respected fighters
will step into the ring
to duke it the [__] out this is the
highly anticipated matchup
and there's no better place to get in on
the action than draftkings
america's top-rated sportsbook app for
this weekend's big fight
you're going to get a shot at turning a
dollar into 55
when you bet on either main event
fighter to win
55-1 odds that's right bet one dollar
and if the fighter of your choice wins
you win 55 [__] dollars
draftkings has fight props also try it
today
basketball and hockey playoffs are right
around the corner
draftking sportsbook is safe secure
and reliable meaning you can deposit and
withdraw your funds
at your [__] convenience so do
yourself a favor
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app
today right now and use promo code joey
when you sign up
for a limited time only new users new
new users i'm sorry about that can bet a
dollar
one dollar to win 55 on this weekend's
main event
draftking sportsbook app is going all
out for new users by offering them
this chance to win 55
when placing a bet of one dollar on this
weekend's big fight
only at draftkings sportsbook that is
the fine print i gotta read
you gotta be 21 over new jersey indiana
or pa only new customers only
restrictions apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details now
if you got a gaming problem call 1-800
gambler
in indiana 1-809 with it no but if you
don't have no problems and you're
[__] straight
download the draftking sportsbook app
for this weekend's fight
and make some [__] getus it's
mother's day this sunday you got to be
ready for mom you know what i'm saying
also the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com
listen you know what this life is about
saving time
and money life is a [__] long journey
but you ain't got time
to be standing at the [__] post
office we're looking for parking and all
this [__]
or paying full price on postage that's
why
i use and recommend stamps.com
my wife loves it you can send letters
packages
anytime anywhere right from your [__]
computer and with stamps.com
you pay a lot less you get discounted
rates from usps
ups and more stamps.com has saved
businesses
thousands of hours and stacks of cash my
wife
loves it she sends out shirts she sends
out patches whatever the mugs
if you're a small business owner
stamps.com
is a must-have stop wasting time going
to the post office
and go to stamps.com instead there's no
risk
and with my promo code joey you get a
special offer that includes
no long-term commitment free postage and
a digital scale
and no contracts just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in joey
stamps.com promo code joey
stamps.com never ever go to the post
office again
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion i'll find out today who won the
playstation 5.
hopefully it's somebody from the joint
but if not
hey what the [__] you gonna do cbd lion
is the leader in cbd
they proved it to me again last week
they sent me some cbd
[__] melatonin gummies oh my god the
berry
i've been sleeping like a [__] baby
except for wednesday night when i drank
the espresso do yourself a favor and
they just released hemp flower cbd
joints they still got the bath ball
still got the cream
still got the roll on and they're still
the best cbd out there
go to cbd lion read their third party
lab results
you know this ain't no [__] swami
from salami
trying to sell you [__] this is uncle
joey telling you that if you need help
with anxiety
pain you know [__] insomnia
cbd lion might be able to help but it
all starts with you
going to cbdlion.com right now and
reading up
on how cbn cby cbd can help you
go to cbdline.com right now and press in
joey
or church and get 20 off your first
order delivered to your [__] house
no gas station cbd no liquor store cbd
this is the real [__] deal from uncle
joey
go to cbdlion.com preston joey at church
and get 20 off who's better than you
nobody
let's kick this [__] off right
now
uncle joey's joint is coming to you
in full [__] effect let's start this
[__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday may the 3rd a whole new
month
a whole new set of goals a whole new set
of [__] priorities
i'm feeling good tip top magoo had a
great [__] weekend
you know it's funny how when you gamble
like
the other day i went to the gym and i
get out of my [__] car
and i look on the you know whatever i
turn around and
i look on the floor and there's a dollar
bill on the [__] floor i go what
i pick up the dollar bill i get the last
three numbers of the
there's like 10 numbers on a dollar bill
i get the last three numbers
and i play to pick it three times it was
like 7 23.
my number came out my birthday number
came out last sunday in new jersey
219 but it came out box it came out 129.
that day i stopped and i bet 219 but i
didn't box it
the dummy that i [__] am you know if
i if i get a minute i'll go over to pick
place and i'll pick the [__] three
numbers or four numbers or six
just something to do you know that's
what you do when you live in [__]
jersey you play the pick three
so i'm like what the [__] i gotta stop
playing i i played the [__] 219
nothing [__] happened then i found a
dollar bill at the gym
i played 7 23 the morning the lunch
number and the night number straighten
box
i got dick and then yesterday i go to
[__]
uh saturday i went to a [__] uh
kentucky derby party i had a great
weekend
i mean we were out listen the house goes
to bed at nine here my
my daughter goes to bed 9 9 30. my wife
follows her like quarter the [__] 10
and then i stay up from 11 to about 12.
i'm in that area
we've been out four nights this week we
didn't get home till [__] 9 30.
i mean it was just a great week a lot of
action games
you know she won the [__] game ball
on saturday we'll talk about that [__]
later
but it was a full [__] week friday
night we had a [__] game
and then we had a dinner with the
families we went over the [__] uh
pizza joint and we invaded this place
you know pizzas and [__] chicken
sandwiches the whole thing for the kids
and then saturday we had a game and
[__] after that
i went to a kentucky derby party like i
said so i'm shell shocked from the week
i haven't picked the winner since the
under of the [__] rose number juma's
fight
two last week the 23rd so i'm sitting
there all week and
there was a game i liked one night this
week an nba game
i didn't put it out on twitter i [__]
came home and i forgot about it and i
[__] would have lost anyway so i was
like thank god i didn't bet it
i'm the kiss of debt this week so i go
to this kentucky derby party yesterday
i'm sitting and i go you know what
they're taking numbers they're like you
know we can take bets if you want them
so i'm sitting there i look at the
[__] lineup and again i don't know
nothing about these horses i don't know
nothing about trainers i know nothing
this is why i say to you you know people
who are very technical like if you ask
joe rogan like i don't know how many
times we've been on a plane together
headed to
ufc and i'll talk to him about somebody
i want to gamble on
and he'll tell me why not to bet that
guy and i'll believe him and then the
guy
the other guy will win because joe knows
fighters to the [__]
he knows everything about fighters he
knows everything about boxing
he knows everything about the trainers
so when people know that much knowledge
they tend to bet and they lose because
there's too much knowledge
you're betting on the [__] line so i
i don't know nothing about nothing
so i'm sitting there yesterday i get the
[__] booklet i'm looking at i go
what's my lucky number eight my mother
died on the eighth
i stopped doing blow on the eighth my
daughter was born on the eighth
as far as i'm concerned it's my lucky
[__] number right so
i go let me bet the [__] eight horse
and then joe florentine
like the nine horse the hot rod whatever
the [__] it was so
the other thing was the eight horse had
the name medina
so i like that song funky cole medina
and i have a friend called sam medina
that me and my brother were talking
about the other day so i said [__] it
i'll put 20 across the board on this
number eight horse medina
and i put 20 across the board on the
nine horse this [__] hot rod whatever
and listen it doesn't really matter if i
win or lose
it's 120 i'm at a party
who cares me and my wife and my wife
took some horses i don't know who the
[__] she bet
next thing you know the race goes off
and i'm like [__] sitting there i
can't see the [__] screen
but then you know what the i said let me
get up a little closer give it some luck
i get up [__] 10 feet
and my horse is coming in i'm like come
on the eight horses and come on
that was just a lucky [__] pick and
all sudden doom the race is over the
eight horse came in
and the nine horse came in third so i
won on the nine horse
and the [__] eight horse then after
the eight horse one i found out that the
trainer was like [__] belichick
he had broken he won [__] eight
kentucky derbies and [__]
people are looking at me like you knew i
didn't know nothing i didn't know
nothing it was the luckiest [__] bet
i've ever made in my life but that just
goes to show you man
you never know what the [__] is gonna
happen in this life you never [__]
know
you know right now i got i spoke to hari
this week i spoke to rogan this week you
know
and they both gave me a little [__]
about not doing stand-up and i go you
know what
there's nothing wrong with that because
something good will come out from all
this
for you guys that don't know on my other
podcast on patreon i let them know on
friday
that i had my first [__] uh
meeting with a book publisher this
friday you know how big that is
do you have any idea how big that is
like i didn't even know
until after i got off the [__] phone
and how big that was the last couple
months i've been
over here yeah we've been doing a
podcast the zooms you guys don't like
whatever the [__] you know
uh but we've been trying at least for
trying that's all that [__] matters
in my world
you know when people say to you well i i
i'm not doing this because
i don't know exactly how to do well
[__] do it and
while you're doing it you'll find the
kinks and you'll work them out it's like
the kids going back to school
they should have been back in [__]
school a year ago
because like that we were we could have
learned we could have learned what's
really [__] happening here
if you put 10 kids together they're
gonna and then we go by we learn
you close in the [__] schools and not
letting them go to school and saying
that we gotta figure it out
it's not gonna [__] pan up this is
why i started doing the [__] podcast
because i knew it would loosen me the
[__] up patreon it would loosen me the
[__] up
and i go back to the early see last week
lee did a podcast with somebody
and he said some pretty interesting
things on that late and they were
talking about
that throughout this whole podcast genre
nobody gave enough credit to brian
redbatt
because brian redmann was the guy who
really pushed these
when how podcasting started for me
how i got introduced to it was
in a window of time that i didn't know
what the [__] was going on
you know 2007 i quit coke i quit cocaine
but while i was in that process of
quitting cocaine
i was also on my name is earl
greg garcia god bless his soul gave me a
reoccurring role
they were that was when earl was stuck
in the prison
with ethan soupley they were great they
were great episodes
a couple weeks ago i had michael rapper
put on and a bunch of you guys got
pissed off at me whatever listen
me and michael rappaport go back to that
season of 2007
with my name is earl and the reason why
greg liked me you know whatever
was because mike rappaport was pulling
for me on the show
while they were shooting michael
rappaport would go hey
this would be a good scene to have joey
in it and they would call me at three in
the afternoon and go joey what are you
doing at like six
can you stop by this set and just do a
scene that's how good they were to me
but i was in a great position i quit
cocaine november of 2007.
i did two more episodes of my name
israel in december
and that meant that in 2008 i was going
into
a new [__] show i was like they were
gonna stay in the prison for the rest of
the year
a lot of people don't know this [__]
story that's why i'm telling you the
story
a lot of people don't know this i was i
and i was so [__] excited because i
go listen
if i'm on a network show during pilot
season
for people who don't know pilot season
used to be
from mid-january to about may
late april i would usually get the call
the end of march because i'm one of the
ugly dudes
they usually start with the leads and
then the [__] other roles and then
they pick the janitors and the [__]
other people
last and that's when i would come in
so i figured that if i was on a [__]
tv show while pilot season was on
i would maybe get put on as a series
regular was perfect
i was off the blow i had a new outlook i
was excited
[__] this is great well put the brakes
on the [__] car
there's a [__] union strike there's a
writer's strike
so my [__] plans of january me being
on a [__] show
were wiped that the slate was wiped
clean i was done
the strike took over and it was
heartbreaking you know i mean i was
listen if you want me to think that i
was throwing things at wall
now it's just it's just a part of
[__] growing up
that you deal with as a man you go what
am i going to do there's nothing i could
do here
there's a writer's strike and after the
strike came back
they weren't gonna do they weren't gonna
be back in the [__] prison so
i got [__] in pilot season i got
[__] out of sixth grade episodes and
my name is earl
i'm not complaining i'm not complaining
i had a big transition period
so we're 2008 right now and the only
thing i got going on really is joe rogan
joe rogan's taking me on the road with
him it's me him
ari duncan you know red band at the time
we had a nice little click going um
i'd worked really hard you know i was
they wouldn't accept me as a stand-up
even though by this time i was a regular
at the store
from 97 2007 all that stuff went down
with rogan and myself
at the store and you know the guy that
was running i forget what his [__]
name was so
that was that was it i wasn't at the
store no more it was 2008.
um you know by this time
i had done the longest shot i had done
spider-man
i had done my name is earl i had done
all this [__] work law and all the
svu
taxi i mean the [__] movies were
endless and the tv shows were endless
but you know what man nothing was
working for me
it just was not working for me at
whatsoever
i was lost i didn't know what to do like
i said the only thing on my compass was
rogan
rogan was the lighthouse at least i had
that every two weeks and don't get me
wrong i was putting my own little gigs
together
but i was really i was at the end of my
[__] rope i i got
i i don't know what else i could do you
know to to win them the [__] over
i have no idea what to do but while i
was going on the road with rogan at
night we would finish up on the road
and then we would go back to joe's room
and we would dick around
and one night brian's like let's just
tape this
you know and i'm like what are you
talking about taped it i'm
and we were taping it and i started
thinking i'm like listen man we're
taping these things
and who's home on a [__] friday night
at midnight 14 year olds
we're basically talking to 14 year olds
a lot of people don't remember this [__]
you know i i was not into it at all i
would hang out up at the rooms me and
ari would go up there and hang out for a
little while
and i just wasn't into this podcast
thing i wasn't buying into it
and then i remember getting a call from
brian one day that um
they weren't going to do that podcast
anymore after the shows
because some kid did dmt and his mother
caught him
he he blamed it on listening to it on
rogan with us that night
and they actually called rogan's manager
people forget about this [__] i don't
forget about none of this [__]
so i was turnt off the podcasting like
i'm like i'm see what i'm saying
do you see them [__] saying some
[__] kid was listening at midnight on
[__] friday night why are we getting
together on a friday night at midnight
people are out doing blow eating ass
doing drugs getting in trouble eating
pills
[__] knuckleheads are home on a
friday night kids you know they're just
kids they're home they got no money to
go out
and you're gonna [__] pop up on their
screen and they're gonna [__] you
know
so i was like i i don't know what the
[__] i want to do but on the other side
of stand up
like i was good i was i was really
[__] good at stand up at this time
but guys it just wasn't working there's
nothing you could do sometimes
people fall but between the holes you
know i saw this whole
thing happened and it was so beautiful
and i want to tell you how it went down
[__] step by step so
one of those nights i went out to dinner
with my wife
i don't know where the [__] we were we
were at some [__] restaurant
and it was busy they had a couple of
valets there was a place in encino
they had valets running running i forget
the name of the restaurant to be honest
here now i'm seeing it in my head
and one of the kids came over to me you
know they usually have mexican valets
this guy was a little arab kid nice kid
sweet kid came over to me he's like joey
you don't know me my girlfriend's a
comic slash
whatever she does a show on
thursday nights where you just tell
stories
we don't want you to do no stand up
there's no stand up allowed
you have to go up there and tell a
[__] story and i'm like really
this is weird so i was struggling with
my stand up i was a good stand-up
but there was something missing from my
stand up
it was the personalization of my
stand-up
i was just doing one-liners i felt like
rodney dangerfield i was trying to copy
rodney
for a lot of people that say you
resemble not resemble but
your comedy because i was trying to be
rodney for a long time i was in the
middle of rodney andrew dice clay bill
hicks
pryor i let you know those are the guys
that affected me lenny clark
i loved that style of comedy paul mooney
so but i wasn't catching what they were
doing the reason why they were
successful
because they were connecting with the
audience members i was
funny but i wasn't connecting with the
audience
big [__] difference and i want you to
think about that a lot of people don't
think about that
you have to make a connection with that
audience funny is funny people
laughing on the way out they'll go he
was a funny guy the second guy that went
up before rogan
but he's not making a connection like
rogan's making like greg geraldo was
making like all these guys were making
so i went and i it was like a thursday
night
some bar it wasn't even a bar to be
honest it was a coffee shop
trying to correct myself it was a coffee
shop
that maybe sat 16
it was in the back of like a [__]
restaurant
and i went and i told the story
and i remember getting in the car
afterward i don't ask for what story i
told i think i told
i told the story about maybe mr martini
or something like that like i was
thinking about 88th street 205.
when i got off i remember she thanked me
and i got in the car and i'm like that
was
interesting it was a funny story like i
got laughs
it was interesting i guys i wish i could
remember the story
that and i enjoyed my i was like that
was [__] great you know that i
i got to tell a story instead of going
up there and just telling one-liners
and about a week later i got a call from
the funny bones
and they were trying to book me in
uh a couple clubs like they were like
what we're trying to do is get
guys that don't sell out improvs and put
them in funny bones and i was like that
sounds great but this was
just brought me back to something that
happened with with billy gardell
i remember going to burbank one day to a
starbucks to meet a guy to write
and as i was walking towards my car
there's a hamburger joint next to the
starbucks it's a famous
mel's mel's burgers and on friday nights
that's where jay leno brings his cars
and a bunch of people bring their cars
like from the 50s and they they try to
like do doo-wop and all this [__]
anyway it's got nothing to do with this
i'm just explaining the restaurant to
you [__]
if you're ever in burbank and you want
to go knock yourself out but
i saw billy was sitting there by himself
right before he got
to show with the girl on cbs
it had to be maybe three months before
he got this this is
a couple years before that and
[Music]
i saw him sitting there and i went billy
what's going on you know i knew billy
from the comedy scene
and he goes ah these [__] funny bones
made me an offer it's not even worth
[__] doing when you think about it
you know i don't know what the [__] i'm
gonna do when i go billy it's just an
awful blah blah blah and then i had i
didn't see billy again and
god bless me months later he got the
show with uh
melissa or whatever her name is i don't
even know if that's her name
mccarthy i don't know and he became
famous billy gardel
but now i was on that end i'll never
forget that when i was on the phone with
the [__] funny bones i was thinking
about billy years earlier
and i [__] go they offered me like
shitty money you know for comedy i don't
know if you guys know what money
shitty money is it was like wednesday
through sunday
so that's wednesday thursday to friday
to saturday and one sunday and they
wanted to give you 1200 bucks
no plane ticket plane tickets were like
300 [__] bucks so
that means i'm clearing nine no
commission but you got to pay taxes
you're not really making any money it's
work joey be happy with it
by that point i was like you know what
man
i'll do it but cut sunday and they were
like we can't do that
if we cut sunday we need to cut money
off the thing and i was like you know
what
this is something i don't even want to
[__] do
i'm having a great time going out with
rogan he pays me well
we eat well he takes care of me plus i'm
around great comics when i'm with him
i just do that i'm not gonna get
involved in this [__] no more in fact
i'm gonna get a [__] job i'm not
gonna do [__] stand up around town
you know i just moved to the valley in
i got married i moved to the valley
and i was like i made a decision i said
i'll tell you what i'm gonna [__] do
i'm gonna [__] do stand-up a couple
nights a week
you know 100 here 200 here 50 here
and i'll go on the road with rogan but i
think it's time to get a [__] day job
am i quitting stand up not really
but i'm not doing this a hundred percent
i've got guys like greg garcia i've got
friends that are writers that
throw me stuff from time to time you
know i was getting
you know maybe four calls a year from
friends just give me a [__] movie
or a tv show which is [__] better
than nothing
so i figured [__] it i'll just do that
i'll get a [__] day job
and i'll keep pushing you know whatever
i'll be a husband
i'll stay in at night more i'm not going
to the store you know i'm not doing all
these things you know i might as well
just
focus on being a husband focus on
[__] uh
you know a little stand-up i'm gonna do
and i'll focus on the job
i'll try to i'll try to get a job
selling something so i put a resume
together
2009 a lot of you guys don't know this i
put a resume together
i made up the phony college [__] the
credits
and the [__] you know all the [__]
and
i went online and started sending out
resumes to become a [__] salesman
you know i got a few calls back you know
there weren't nothing i wanted not to be
a traveling salesman
i wouldn't like to sell [__] on the
phone like to just check up on people
whatever the [__] it was
maybe you have an 800 line number for a
[__]
couch company and people call in with
leads it's not like i'm cold calling
people
i want to try different i love selling i
love talking to people on the phone i
don't give a [__]
so i sent out a bunch of resumes
you know i got nothing who the [__]
gonna call a [__]
40 year old loser for a [__] kid's
job so nobody [__] calls i said
[__]
i'll go back to what i know what i do
selling [__] cars
so i went to a couple dealerships in the
area
walking distance from my house you know
me i'm a lazy [__]
i applied to the ford store i applied to
i think it was a nissan store
and i think there was a toyota store and
all three of them said they would take
me but the ford store really wanted me
the fourth store was in love with me
they were they were all in they liked
the experience
it was a liner closer type deal they
were gonna [__] make me a closer
right off the bat
but there was a kink in the deal i had
to give them a clean year analysis
that wasn't happening i was smoking dope
with three hands
the revolution of dope was just starting
to [__] happen
and you know i'm not
i'm not [__] quitting dope so the
guy's like listen
just find yourself like fake piss or
whatever
take the test pass it and they were even
i mean they were willing to work around
my schedule
they were like we even let you go on the
weekends and do comedy just come here
during the week
put in as many hours as you can a lot of
people don't [__] know this about me
but there's two sides to this [__]
story one day i got a call from ari
and he goes hey man do me a favor i want
to try this thing
in the improv there's not even booze
being served
there's no [__] money at all being
paid
it's just an experiment would you mind
doing it for me come down and tell a
story
i go what story do you want me to tell i
mean i i already knows a lot of my life
he goes tell a story about you going to
prison
i had never i was [__] embarrassed i
had never talked about this before
you know i was like wow
i go all right you know i'll go down and
[__] tell a story i get down there
mark marian's there and marc maron is
telling a story about a concert
and i go wow so whatever story i thought
about
whatever portion i was going to talk
about the kidnapping and whatever
i go [__] this i'm going to go up there
and tell a pink floyd story when i took
ahead of acid and went and got playing
floyd tickets
and the whole [__] thing and i went
down and did it
and felt great about it and when i got
there and got off i think steve agee was
there was me
steve agee and uh i think that's how you
say his name stephen g
whatever he hangs out with sarah
silverman and mark maron i went up after
mark
and we told this pink floyd story
and a couple days later ari put it up on
youtube
and i'm like let me take a look at it i
mean i hate watching myself but let me
[__] take a look at this thing
and i [__] took a look at this thing
and i'm like wow
that's completely different [__] than
what i do on stage
i gotta start leaning towards that i
gotta figure out a way how to [__]
lean towards storytelling
on stage and this you know
this is the way to go to help my act
but at that time i really wasn't putting
that much focus and i'm like
it might work it might not work
what if i tell a story and people don't
like it how am i going to come back from
that you know i told the story about
finding my mother on stage one night on
aston in some city
when i was opening up for joe it was a
complete the story was great
but then i couldn't go anywhere from
there i just bombed once you find your
mother on the floor
there ain't no [__] place to go from
there you know they ain't no
joking you can't follow that you know
what i'm saying people [__] got tears
in their eyes i'm like what have i done
i'm trying to be funny here to tell this
[__] story and people got tears in
their eyes i [__] myself so i'm like
how am i going to make this [__] work
this was all like a process
so i'm like you know even though i don't
want to be a stand-up full-time anymore
i still would like to be a better
stand-up there's nothing wrong with
being better
you know so
they're calling me from the ford store
you know hey how's it going are you
are you staying clean i'm like listen
bro i'm just weaning myself off from
reefer
i'm not staying clean i had made some
calls to figure out how to get
[__] piss everybody i asked everybody
i knew got high
it's not like i didn't know anybody who
didn't get [__] high so where was i
gonna get pissed from
you know when i lived in colorado i had
a few neighbors that i would go up to
them with the jar and go hey
piss in here for me you know and they
would understand but in
california people i didn't know who to
ask you go up to somebody in california
you tell me you want piss
god can you imagine right now somebody
[__] saying on a video yeah 10 years
ago joey diaz called me up looking for
piss
i don't know what he was going to do
with it that's a complete different
[__] so i didn't even ask anybody
this is way somebody told me that they
sold piss at head shops
fake piss some synthetic piss i couldn't
[__] find it so
i was like give me a couple more weeks
and i'll try to get [__] clean off
this weed and my numbers will go down
they're calling me every [__] day can
you please we need you on the line i'm
like holy [__]
what the [__] have i done here and then
all this
i still got brian you know which is
funny because i talked to brian
thursday night this week and i called
them because
i was going to my computer and i found
uh i'm going to post a few things i
found this weekend
i'm finally cleaning up a bunch of [__]
guys you know i people keep asking me
when can i get a p.o box
i'm not getting [__] because i'm still
[__] putting away [__] i just took a
bunch of clothes upstairs this morning
i got up early and i [__] took a
bunch of clothes upstairs that i found
um there was a bunch of [__] that was
going on right now and
red band we did i we did for a while
there me brian
and ari were getting together on my
front balcony
and we were doing a podcast outside
called podcats
i don't know if anybody remembers that
podcast podcasts put cats
and we just talk about [__] cats and
i'm like this is the dumbest thing i've
ever done in my life
but i got to do something with my life i
mean let's at least talk about [__]
cats
you know i got i had nine cats at the
time now i'm down to three
you know they die over the [__] years
you can't take them white wish they
could
all still be here but and two of them on
their last leg they're just holding on
to dear life
but uh it's gonna be a sad day when they
go and their two sisters
and they were brothers with their
sisters with super bad but anyway who
gives a [__] about the cats
we're not talking about cats right now
but that's how it started we did about
six episodes of podcats and i still
i found what i found the other day
wasn't the actual [__] podcast
i found the notes i would make to talk
about calico and you know
uh [__] whatever blue and [__]
siamese cats and
i found the notes i'm like i was making
actual [__] notes for that
i forgot all about that so
brian was still with the podcast thing
like are you gonna ever do a podcast i'm
like no
why so if i smoke a joint on there i'm
gonna get a call from some kid's mother
that a 13 year old [__]
oh deed on a joint because i smoked a
joint on a [__] podcast that's the
last thing i [__] need so no
i'm not doing any [__] podcast i
refused
but all of a sudden i get another call
from ari
and he's like hey we're doing that show
again do you mind coming down i'm like
really another storyteller show okay
this is fun
maybe i'll get to do another [__]
story and i wrote i don't even know what
story i told them the second one
again it was back and they were we were
doing them in the annex
we weren't even doing them at the
[__] improv that's why i give ari all
the credit in the world he got that show
and he started it in the [__] annex
with no booze
it was people just sitting there no
drinking no nothing
they didn't even have curtains up it was
just a [__] eight inch brick wall
not even the [__] bricks block it was
a block wall no curtain no nothing
i felt like i was going there to get
shot like somebody's gonna ask me do you
want the last cigarette
like there was nothing there so just i
forget what story i told there
and again it [__] worked i'm like
[__] it this is great the storytelling
[__]
is [__] great you know
and i get a call from the ford store dog
we need you you got to come and pass so
i said [__] it i'll go down there
and give it a shot they go if you piss
and if you fail
you can't get it you got to come back in
a year you got to wait a whole [__]
year so are you ready for this i go dog
listen
i've been smoking light lately what's
life for me maybe a joint or two a day
compared to the 22 i was smoking for the
last [__] 28 years
let's go give it a shot and i went down
there and i pissed in a bottle
and they were like listen you came back
hotter than [__]
your car salesman days are over with and
i'm like
everything happens for a reason and i
think the next day
i bumped into felicia michaels
at the coffee shop on colfax now i had
met felicia
in 1994
at the comedy works in denver
she was one of the hottest comics
working in the country at that time
she had just one star search she had
just posed in playboy
you know i was a young comic i mean i
wasn't a young kid
i was already in a whole long and a 2 32
year old 33 year old
in 1994
i'm clocking myself maybe 32 yeah i was
born in 33
so 63 so in 94
i'm 31 maybe 95 i'm 32.
i had to be 32 and i was doing an open
mic on a tuesday night
and we were in the comedy works in
denver and in denver the headliner of
the week
it starts headlining on wednesday but
they pay you extra money to fly in on
tuesday
and just do a half hour for the open mic
to draw people to the open mic so the
open mic is gonna have an audience which
i thought was great
and i watched her do a set
and i [__] dyed a laughter and
afterward i just went up to her
and i was like that was great i had i
didn't know
of felicia i had seen her on the mtv
half hour comedy hour before
and i was like she's pretty [__] good
and she's beautiful
you know i could be as honest as i can
to you when i went up to her
i didn't go up to her with any uh thing
of hitting on her or anything
i really went up to it to tell her that
was [__] great you know and
what do i just want to ask advice in
those days
whenever i saw a comic i would always go
up to them that i liked that i
was kind of cool with and i would always
go if there was one piece of advice
you could give me you know and i went up
to her and i told her i liked the set
and it was some like hollywood [__]
where people don't make eye contact with
you
she made eye contact with me and she
took the time
like she was like you have to get on
stage you know
don't worry about a manager an agent
don't worry about headshots just get the
real [__] patois
stand up you know just get up there
that's all you got to do is just get up
there you know
and it'll come to you but keep getting
up there don't get discouraged
she gave me such great advice that i was
so thankful to her
like i was so grateful to her because
sometimes when people give you advice
they give you advice and a weird
tone like oh this again you know
she didn't do that and because of that
lesson that i learned from felicia when
comics come up to me with advice
i don't give them a third eye i i
um a stink eye you know i
actually make eye contact with them and
i
i tell them what i think is the perfect
thing for them
you know which which is just get on
stage
you know all this other [__] you talk
it's like when you talk to a foreigner
and he's like
this is [__] this is pure [__] you know
it's the same thing
it's like when you come up to me and
you're like i don't know what to do my
my material listen get on stage you're
doing comedy three years
guess what nobody gives a [__] i wish i
could look in the eye and tell you that
somebody gives a [__]
nobody gives a [__] this is one of the
best times of your life
when nobody gives a [__] you go up there
and do whatever the [__] you want you
have a free [__] pass
it's when you're doing comedy eight
years that somebody will come up to you
and go
you've been doing comedy eight years and
you're still playing the banjo with your
teeth and you're like i thought it works
no you know when you're doing comedy
three years that's the beauty about
doing comedy for three years
you could do whatever the [__] you want
nobody's gonna say something
who's that dummy with the suit on oh
he's an open mic he's just a [__]
that's what i'm saying but meanwhile
you're making [__]
i knew that every time i touched the
stage in the beginning
that i was making strides like i didn't
beat myself up
i was i could be as honest as i can with
you
and tell you that my first two or three
years of comedy i didn't beat myself up
because i figured out
it was getting on stage it was a numbers
game it's just numbers just keep going
and let people make fun of you
and let them say you suck play them and
said i sucked to me my own friends
my own friends that i grew up with would
tell me joey
those jokes are [__] brutal you know
what that feels like it's a
heartbreaking but it's a part of [__]
life
but i use those three years to my
advantage like
just do whatever the [__] i wanted back
to the [__] story at hand here
so i bumped into felicia in this coffee
shop
that was right by my house and i sat
down with her and we started yakking
and you know catching up and she had
just gone through a divorce
you know she was lost you know when you
go through a divorce
people have to pick sides when people go
through a divorce
sometimes people are forced to pick
sides felicia was in a tough
situation
because she was married to a big-time
comedy manager
comics a horse so if you looked at
felicia and looked at this comedy
manager
even if that comedy manager wasn't your
you didn't want a situation where in the
future you're going to get big
and that guy is not going to be your
manager because you're friends with his
ex-wife
if you follow him saying to you so when
i
bumped into felicia from my conversation
with her
i could tell that she was grateful that
i was talking to her because
this divorce had set had pushed comics
away from her in a way that it
made her like standoffish just just the
way it is in la
if this would happen anywhere else
people would still be their friend but
in l.a god forbid
you know this guy could be my manager
someday someday i might have a big movie
so i i spoke to her a few times and i go
hey felicia
all these people are doing [__]
podcasts
let's give it a [__] shot
and she was like let's give it a shot i
mean we didn't even know where to start
guys it wasn't like
nobody i i called red band and i go red
band i'm thinking of starting a podcast
with felicia
what do i need and he gave me a [__]
list of [__]
and we went to the guitar center and we
set it up in the house there was no
instructional manual
there was no youtube videos there was no
ikea videos there was
there was nothing there was nothing
there was just
there was no proof there was no joe
rogan experience
the guy at that time when we started was
the guy from the man show
that was it mark maron was rocking and
rolling a little bit
those were the two higher ups there was
maybe
maybe 300 podcasts then
there wasn't the 20 000 podcast there is
now there was nothing
there was nothing to base yourself off
really nothing
we were just going in there myself and
felicia i told like oh the first
two months if you listen to beauty and
the beast now it was just her and i
just [__] figuring it out and i gotta
tell you i listened to one
[Music]
maybe six months ago it was [__]
rough you think the zooms are rough
you should try to listen to one of those
beauty and the beast you'll be running
back to the [__] zooms okay
so it was [__] rough but
we kept doing it but now at the same
time the storytelling [__] started
picking up in l.a
aries doing more storytelling shows
the chick i know is doing more
storytelling shows
i had picked up a little thing my friend
diagostino which you guys know
the agostino zoya the homeschool podcast
he was a manager at taha he was just a
kid
and we became friends and i had a deal
with him that
i would go over to the haha not get put
on the lineup
i would go over to the haha every
[__] night
and close the show up that's how i made
my comeback
into comedy again i wasn't really this
was done
i was gone i was gonna go sell cars i
was gonna do something completely
[__] different
but i was like i gotta give this podcast
there was no money
nobody was making money there was no ads
there was nothing
our first ad was [__] the sex toy
company
they gave us a hundred a month to sell
dildos and [__] like that there was no
[__] money there was
nothing nobody knew nothing about
nothing
but all i know is we had to show up
there every tuesday and
i think we did it once a week or twenty
in the beginning we just did it once a
week
because we didn't [__] know we had
nobody listening to it nobody was
downloading podcasts
this was like [__] you know the
beginnings but we
kept with it we kept doing it and doing
it and we were lost
we could not find the [__] voice of
this [__] podcast
but a funny thing happened on the way to
the [__] circus
see all the storytelling going around
town
got me going and i would sit down every
day and write a different [__] story
i would sit down every day and write a
different story and i don't know if you
guys believe me you go back with me this
far
if any of you [__] could find
my myspace
go on my myspace i wrote the monday
morning blog
for a [__] two years on myspace
that's how when you start
when i start thinking about all this
how this thing came about the last i've
been sitting in this house for the last
eight months thinking about
how the [__] this journey started
where and when did this journey pick up
how i
you know and we've never covered this
[__] like people ask me all the time how
the [__]
you know what i'm giving you the answer
i didn't know anything about anything
it's 2 000 [__] 10 and
i'm not selling tickets i'm not
i was getting better as a comic i think
i think i was in a transition period
i was starting to tell stories and
trying to do jokes at the same time
i didn't even know what i was doing but
something else that i was doing
came into that i never told anybody i
think i mentioned it twice
over the last 10 years on podcast
i looked within and i knew one thing i
knew that
i was funny let's get this out of the
way
i was funny was i the funniest guy on
the block no
but even after doing stand-up at the
17-year mark
17 years
[__] 10 of them
being at the store the world famous
comedy store
i still didn't have it down
as a good comic it didn't really i was
trying to find the balance 17 years
you're doing something
17 [__] years and you cannot find the
balance
that sucks but
through the storytelling shows
i started picking it up i was eating big
bags of dicks
i remember going out with josh wolfe and
we were laughing like
dog i paid four bags of dicks this week
i went out four nights with him
and i died that's why josh has a video i
think him and bill burr were talking
about
nobody bombs like me oh there was a
period where
[__] and i was just bombing and loving
it and not caring
because i didn't give a [__] i'm i was
experimenting
this was all new to me but i was
i don't want to tell you i was
frustrated
i knew i could improve so i didn't say
nothing to nobody
every thursday night when a comic came
into town
at the irvine improv i would take a ride
by myself
smoke a number park in the garage at the
improv
and walking through the back door and
there was a little table on the side
where you could sit [__] nobody even
knew i was there
the waitresses would say hi to me i
would just sit at this little side
and for a year i'm lying to you
let's say for nine months every thursday
i'm
maybe i missed four thursdays and a year
nine months i went to see a different
headliner
and watched him from the side watched
them objectively
between you and i took notes i would
bring a little notebook with me
i wouldn't make notes of their material
not at all
i would make notes of what their
strengths were
and how i could be as strong as them
that was on the ride home before i got
in the car
i would ride what their strengths were
and on the ride home
i would think about what i needed to do
to be like greg geraldo to be like dave
vettel
to be like [__] uh the elephant in
the room the big black dude that i
[__] loved i can't
think of his name patrice o'neill to be
like rich vars
i went down and i actually studied them
i wasn't going to the store i wasn't
going anywhere i wasn't even at the
store at that time
and i went down there so i was trying to
get an idea
of what i wanted to do again
this is at the [__] uh 18-year mark
of doing comedy
2008 you know i've been doing comedy
since 91.
so i was learning i yearned to learn
i [__] yearned i'm like i'm gonna get
this
i heard mitzi shaw once say that you
don't know what stand-up is
till you're doing it for 20 years so i
was like you know what
i'm gonna have to wait till 2000 [__]
eleven
if i'm gonna quit i'm not gonna do this
i'll wait till 2011.
so even though while i was transitioning
and not doing so much stand up
this is why i'm not upset right now
that i'm not doing stand-up because even
though i'm not doing stand-up
i'm putting a book together which
guys it's all i ever wanted to do the
last 20 years i just wanted to have that
thing
author next to my name so since i moved
in here
even though at times i feel like i'm not
carrying my load
the podcast isn't working all this [__]
isn't working
guess what i'm doing i'm sticking to a
schedule that is
so great of me i'm sticking to a workout
routine
i'm sticking to a schedule in the last
since the surgery since january
eric and i have put together close to
five chapters in a book
and i don't know if you guys have been
following my story on ryan sickler
those are some long [__] chapters
okay this book is gonna be [__]
long as [__] they're gonna edit it as we
go along
you know i spoke to the publisher and he
asked me goes
why did you give up on your one man show
i go
i didn't give up on it it gave up on me
you can't fit that much material in 70
[__] minutes
unless i want to keep you guys there for
three hours on a one-man show
and that's not nobody is that special
that you want to see him for three
[__] hours tell a story
there's no way it's an hour 10 and then
your hemorrhoid starts to [__] burn
and you got you already heard mine
burning that's not a fart that's a chair
thing
but what i'm trying to say to you is
that's what happens you start moving
you start getting uncomfortable i don't
want to do that so i explained to them
that
the 70 minute mark wasn't gonna work so
to get back to the [__] story here
i'm trying to tell you guys
podcasting wasn't working for us we
weren't the top podcast
we weren't making it happen but
something happened on the way to the
dance
it always does always keep that in mind
no position
listen unless you're at home and you're
just watching tv all day
and not trying then the odds are stocked
against you you're not going to do [__]
if you're sitting there if you if you
want to write an album
for your band if your band's waiting for
you right now and you're sitting at home
watching tv it looks like that album is
never gonna [__] come
it's never gonna [__] come if you're
sitting there making notes every day
and you're struggling with it but you're
sticking to it every day four or five
days a week
and even though you're struggling with
it like the way i'm struggling with the
guitar
i was really struggling with it but if
you do it
four or five days a week even if it's
for 15 minutes
eventually something good is gonna
happen
i didn't get my my act was struggling
the podcast was struggling and then
something happened on the way to the
dance
me and felicia were going back and forth
and what i was doing was i had sirius in
my car
so when i would drive around i would
drive around listening to sirius
and i would go [__] you know i got to
get the podcast
to be more like these serious shows i'm
listening to
you know at that time it was eddie trunk
florentine jim norton
and uh you know opiate anthony i was
listening to those guys
and i was like i wanted to be more like
that but then i go wait a second
podcasting is podcasting radio
is radio there's two different [__]
things and if you look at
what's going on in the world today
what's going on in life today
radio is not out doing anything anymore
i mean we got like maybe four hosts
that you still listen to but podcasts
are blowing up all these listen to
podcasts
all [__] day long and there's a
reason for that and this is what i
didn't understand
i was trying to do radio on a podcast
and if it was and it wasn't for the day
that me and felicia were talking
maybe i had a bong hitting me maybe i
didn't who the [__] knows
and i'll never forget that she we had
little things that could cover you like
a spit guard
is that what you call them like a spit
card i couldn't really [__] see
anything
i couldn't see her and we were just
[__] yakking back and forth about
something
and i told the story about mugging the
hooker and lighting her wig
on fire i don't know what made me say
i thought about my friend and i'm like
hey i would tell you i had a friend that
we used to use as a model
and we used to put them out there and
[__]
you know uh guys like confused guys
would [__] drive up to him
and asked him if he could suck his dick
and then we would [__] mug him
you know we were talking about that and
then i told the story about
speaking of muggins one night we
actually went into the city
and while my friend was getting his dick
sucked god rest his soul
we mugged the [__] hooker we took her
back to [__] jersey and mugged her
and lit her wig on fire i'll never
forget that i was
so into telling the story i was focused
on the microphone
i was telling the story and something
made me pop up
like and look at felicia and next thing
i know is
she was looking straight at me and her
jaw
was had dropped and when i looked at her
i go
holy [__] that's
what a [__] podcast is her jaw
dropped for a [__] reason
i was blown away we kind of wrapped it
up and
felicia you okay she's like joey that
[__] story kind of disturbed me
it was weird i don't know if we should
put it up you know you're mugging a
hooker and i'm like felicia
there's radio and there's podcasts we
got to bring this [__] part just
put it up put it up if they hate it they
hate it if they want to come arrest me
they'll come arrest me
but this is what needs to be done i
could be wrong
i could be wrong i've been wrong before
i don't [__] know everything
let's put the [__] podcast up and
sure enough
dawg i started getting twitter hits it
was crazy
but the real true test of what had
happened
how two worlds had combined because
that's what happened from 2007
to 2010 until we started the podcast
even though i wasn't focused on stand up
this is the weirdest thing i was focused
on different things
and eventually it all came together and
made my stand up that much better
but once i told that story this is the
[__] craziest thing
guys i did the longest shot it [__]
was the number one movie in america
you know i mean when you watch it you
could tell i didn't know what i was
doing
but i still did a great job i thought
people were going to come in the droves
to come see me and stand up i thought it
would raise my statue
as a stand-up it did dick
you know the my name is earl now we're
on tv i thought they were going to do
something for my stature nothing
nothing nothing i did help me
nothing it didn't put me from a to z
but telling a story
about mugging a hooker and lighting a
wig on fire
so i told the story i didn't think much
of it
you know i got some twitter people i got
some messages
that story was disturbing but i don't
know if you guys remember when cat
williams blew up
kat williams blew up because of one
[__] joke
and if you you got to watch it it's the
most disturbing
joke you'll ever hear in front of you
know he took it to his own he took it to
the african-american community
and he said uh you know you guys like
michael jackson or
he's still sniffing little kids [__]
or little kids booty holes or something
and brother that [__] room i think
you have to go back to cat's first
special
and see the reaction that he got when he
told that joke
that's the reaction whenever you do a
[__] joke that we pray for you're not
gonna get it
that's the kind of jokes i want to write
that you get that mixed [__] reaction
because that mixed reaction
is what you take home with you and break
down and now joey diaz stays in your
head
cat william stays in your head patrice
o'neal stays in your head
uh bill burr stays in your head that's
the connection that i was looking for
that i didn't have
so all those years through stand-up and
through podcasting they met
and the storytelling so between ahri's
storytelling
the podcasting storytelling it met
we became podcasters and that was the
end of [__] radio
and that's why we tell stories on
[__] podcasts
but on top of that aries this is not
happening
took off in a different [__]
direction also
because people were sick and tired of
that style of whatever
people want to hear the nuts and bolts
of your [__] life
they don't and this is what i'm doing
with the book but the lesson today is
that's most important on a beautiful
monday may the third
two days before cinco de mayo even
though i haven't seen a mexican
it's got to be three [__] weeks i
have not seen a mexican in this area
i don't even know where to [__] eat
mexican food there's a new taco stand
that opened up that people are raving
about
but it's an hour and a half awake go
[__] yourself i ain't waiting for food
this ain't [__] evan of cuba
my point of the podcast today was to let
you know that right now
even though i may not be doing stand-up
and i may feel a little bit sub-human
about myself
and not doing stand-up i'm still making
things happen
and they're making me proud more than
ever have i been this proud of
as i'm doing right now yeah i'm missing
out on stand-up and i'm not doing it
i am writing a couple jokes that i'm not
gonna lie to you
when and will i get back on stage
i don't know when i feel it your
[__] will be the first to know
i'm sure that any week now one of these
weeks now
i'm gonna get a call from rich and jimmy
and they're gonna go hey
i'm going to tips tonight i'm going to
uncle vinnie's tonight i'm going to
you know the gold jewel comedy the
whatever sam tripley's room
and i'm gonna say let me you know what
let me go down there with you
and i'm probably gonna start with a
couple ten minute sets
then i'll bring it back to uncle
vinnie's and go for the hour sets
and then take it from there but whether
that day isn't a coming out
i have no [__] idea i'm hoping it
comes
for your sake and for my sake so we can
connect
but if it doesn't i'm still [__]
making strides happen because i'll tell
you what
when they come back with you know i
think i got another meeting with a
publisher this week
so i think i'm going to meet with three
publishers i'm not going to tell you the
names it really doesn't matter
one of them the first one i met with his
[__] huge i'm very
proud i'm very proud of my agent i'm
this agent has the patience of a [__]
monument because he's been waiting for
this book for seven
[__] years we had our first meeting
when i shot like mafia 2
or something like that we've been
talking for six or seven years
i've been trying to put this book
together for seven [__] years and i
failed miserably i'm not embarrassed to
tell you
this is part of it because you shouldn't
be embarrassed to ask for help
and that's what i did with erica
florentine and this is why
we made it this far so far with the book
i'm also writing a tv show with a friend
of mine
howard whether it gets picked up it
doesn't [__] matter i don't give a
[__] about the money
well joey nobody's paying you who cares
i'm just
trying to stay busy with writing the
[__] sitcom
writing the book working on the podcast
eventually this will come back
or something else will come from it what
it will be
i have no [__] idea do you see a
crystal ball there no
neither do [__] eye so we're all
[__] this together
and that's my [__] podcast for today
it's monday
the 3rd of may what i wanted to tell you
from before early in the thing was
my daughter won the game ball on [__]
saturday you know why
because the switch went off remember a
couple months ago we covered the switch
i just saw the switch go off in front of
my [__] eyes
and it was a beautiful thing you know
this move wasn't about me and it wasn't
about my [__] wife it was about my
daughter
i wanted her to have the childhood
stories i had the childhood bonds
that i had i wanted to have all these
little things
and jesus christ what i'm watching
happen
is something completely [__]
different than what i expected
you know i watched her play i don't know
i watched it do five practices
five [__] games and
you know i watched the kid go it's like
my first two years of stand-up
i was just going somewhere to do comedy
that's it i was just going somewhere to
do comedy
it took me to come to new york in 93 to
meet people like mike bushetti
to go to these clubs to realize this is
what i want to do
and this is how i got to do it from now
on
i saw her going
and not rushing for balls no
pardon the [__] express you know to
charging balls now she's playing third
base
she's charging balls i saw her the other
day on saturday
turn around and go we got two outs team
we got two outs
i see her in the dugout in between
[__] things
singing little songs with her
girlfriends i don't even know the
[__] songs
about we will we will rock you and all
this [__]
and i see her grow and it's a beautiful
[__] thing
you know i i'm happy that you guys are
watching me grow the last nine months on
this [__] podcast seven months
whatever the [__] we've been doing you
know when i got here it was a rough
patch my mind was in a bunch of places
but by writing by working out you know
i'm working out four
days a week now i'm 58 years old
i do two hard days i do two recovery
days
i'm only supposed to be doing 61 weight
watcher points that's my goal
for the thing i've been hitting 70 for
the last three [__] weeks
you know i worked myself up every week
more and more and more and more
so yeah i might not be doing stand-up
but i'm making strides in a different
part of my life my marriage is great
i'm having a great time as a dad you
know last night i went out to dinner
saturday we went out to [__] the
party sunday they had something in the
daytime a kid's plan had two kids
parties in the daytime
and then we went out to dinner sunday
night with one of our neighbors across
the street
to a great little japanese steakhouse so
listen guys uh
i'm getting better every day i'm getting
stronger every day
i am down to a bowl of
reefer a day now i know
some of yous are not going to believe
that
and it's not even before two o'clock
i've been smoking lately
at 10 30 at night before i play the
guitar i get
nice and stoned you know i i had to
switch it all around
i put my 35 weed away
and i turned it all the way back to 26
i'm doing this listen guys this is uncle
joey [__] 2.0 here
you know uh my wife told me the other
day something that i did not
even have a clue on we're gonna have a
guest on and
in a couple weeks and him and i were
talking about my coffee intake
my coffee intake used to be a cup of
coffee for breakfast
then after the cup of coffee i would jam
two espressos
then at about two o'clock in the
afternoon i would do like three [__]
espressos
and then at a quarter eight every night
i would do four espressos
you know thank god i was using stevia
and not [__] real sugar
and and putting a cuban coffee together
thank god i'd be 800 pounds
that's not the point that coffee was
feeding my anxiety
i realized that when i was doing that
afternoon cup of coffee and then you
know
an edible was not far around the [__]
corner
so between the edibles and the [__]
coffee
my anxiety and between the fear i had a
covert and all this [__]
my anxiety was to an all-time [__]
high
you know my wife told me on thursday
last week she hasn't ordered espresso
since october
because i stopped drinking coffee
altogether what happened was wednesday
night i went out to eat with the kids
with jim florentine his kid and my
daughter and i got a double espresso
at like 8 30 at night and the next day i
realized i didn't [__] sleep i'm like
what the [__] happened last night
i took my [__] uh you know my
melatonin i took my cbd
lion melatonin gummies [__]
tremendous
i took this i took that and i didn't
[__] sleep
the [__] espresso i told my wife the
next morning she's like joey
i go terry i could drink a flat white at
a quarter to midnight
and be in bed at 12 30. i wouldn't sleep
right obviously i would
obviously wouldn't get gram sleep
but do you know that i drank a double
espresso at dinner
wednesday night and i slept like [__]
when i told my wife that she go sure you
slept like [__]
you haven't drank express like what do
you i forgot all about it
like what are you talking about she goes
joey you were drinking close to [__]
eight espressos a day i was restocking
that the little container where we put
the little single
thing she goes i was restocking it every
two days
she goes i haven't never mind restock it
i haven't even
ordered expresso since october you
stopped completely
and you know this has just been a
process guys
i was just knocking on this anxiety just
so i could be stronger and i could do
this i was having a lot of [__]
problems
you know listen to my stomach that's
intermittent fasting i'm telling you
i'm coming at you from all [__]
directions anyway thank you very much
for listening now you know the
story of my evolution early on with the
podcasting
and the storytelling it just wasn't
there even at 17 years
of doing stand-up i was still struggling
people know who i was
i had done cds and whatnot but this is
just food for thought to tell you guys
you gotta keep pushing you never know
what's gonna [__]
you sitting on the couch wishing ain't
gonna do nothing for you
i'd rather you do work on something an
hour a day
and after 90 days you'll see what's
going on
and that'll excite you the way i'm
excited now now
i can't wait to talk to erica later on
today we're gonna you know
now we're talking three days a week
because now i know i have something
that a publisher wants so hopefully by
the end of the year we'll have this book
ready for you [__] and uh
this all come from full circle and who
knows when i'll be back for stand-up but
listen
that doesn't mean i gave up i'm just
taking a breather off
so my family can have some fun have a
great week
i love you [__] with all my
heart thank you for watching uncle
joey's joint
monday the third and i'll see you
[__] on cinco de mayo
tip top [__] magoo now
for a word from our sponsors
stay black all right
before we get any going i want to thank
you guys for listening today
i also want to thank stamps.com listen
if you're still going for the [__]
post office
or you're paying full price on postage i
don't know what to tell you
that's why i use stamps.com tremendous
is what i could say
you can send letters ship packages
anytime anywhere
right from your computer and if you're a
small business owner
stamps.com is a must-have why uncle joey
because you print us postage for any
letter any package
any class of mail you ship it anywhere
in the world straight from your laptop
you schedule a pickup and the mailman
will come
to you or you could drop it off yourself
buy print ship it's that simple you get
discounts up to 40 percent off in the
post office rates
and up to 60 percent off all ups
shipping rates
if you're not using stamps.com brother
you're sleeping it's no wonder a million
small businesses already use
stamps dot com with stamps.com you pay
less
and you get discounted rates this is
tremendous why are you wasting time
going to the post office
go to stamps.com instead it's no risk
listen to what i'm doing for you with
promo code joey you're going to get a
special
offer that includes a four-week trial
free postage and a digital scale plus
no long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in
joey j-o-e-y that stamps.com
promo code joey never ever ever
go to the post office again the joint is
also brought to you by
come on draftkings listen the weekend's
coming
it's mother's day you want to buy moms
and flowers the girlfriend some flowers
you know
you want to have a little getus you
don't need much [__] money
that's why i love draftkings you know
why because 25
goes a long way you're just getting
excited that's it
this weekend saturday night two of
boxing's most and
respected fighters will step into the
ring to bang themselves in their head
20 times this is a highly anticipated
matchup
and there's no better place to get on
the action than draftkings america's top
rated
sportsbook app why joey for this
weekend's big fight
get a shot at turning a dollar one
dollar
into 55 [__] dollars when you bet on
either main event
fighter to win that's 55 to one odds
where the [__] you gonna get that
uncle joey at draftkings that's where
you're gonna get it
you bet one dollar and if your fighter
wins
you get 55 [__] bucks plus draftkings
has fight props too
try it right now plus you got to
remember baseball basketball
and hockey playoffs are right around the
corner baseball's in full effect
draftking sportsbook is safe secure and
reliable
it means that you can deposit and
withdraw funds at your [__]
convenience
where i come from that's a [__]
knockout so do yourself a favor
right now download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app
use promo code joy when you sign up and
for a limited time
you ready for this all new users can bet
one dollar
to win 55 dollars on this weekend's main
event
you heard it right draftking sportsbook
is going all out for new users by
offering them
a chance to win 55
when you place a bet of one dollar on
this weekend's big fight
only at draftking sportsbook app and
here's the fine print
you got to be 21 or older new jersey
indiana
pa new customers only restrictions apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook
for details you got a gaming problem
called 1-800 gambler or in indiana
call 1-809 with it but now
it's time to make some [__] getus
download the draftking sportsbook app
for this weekend's fight and let's make
some [__] money
so you could buy moms and flowers you
get your dick sucked
you could do drugs whatever the [__] you
want to do you could do but it starts
with draftkings
code joey the joint is also brought to
you by
c b d lion
the best sorry about that little cough
there that little [__] piece of gum
in my throat
the best cbd line how do i know
i [__] lived off this stuff for years
now from the cbd lotion
to the cream to the bath ball to the
gummies and now they got a new
gummy infused with melatonin i think
it's 1500 milligrams of cbd
and 25 milligrams of melatonin you eat
four or five of those
you'll be sleeping like a baby and
waking up feeling like a [__] tiger
you understand me
but it starts with you going the cbd
[__] lion
and reading on cbd cby cbn
and how they can be advantageous to you
and how they can help you
with insomnia anxiety pain whatever
you're going through
they got tape they got joints they got
cbd weed now they got listen go to cbd
lion
i could sit here for hours and telling
you the benefits of them but it starts
with you
going over there and seeing what's going
on you find something that works for you
after you read
press in joey or church and get 20 off
on your order delivered to your house
it's that [__] easy i want to thank
draftkings co
joey i want to thank stamps.com
code joey i want to thank cbd lion
co joey at church for sponsoring this
week's episode
but i want to thank you guys for
listening and for the constant support
patreon i love you [__] have a
great week
see you wednesday cinco the [__] mayo
okay
get your burrito whatever the [__] you
need i love you [__] stay black
do
so
[Music]
hmm
so
you